well good evening and thank you for
coming I want to update torontonians on
a difficult personal matter
during the pandemic I developed a
relationship with an employee in my
office in a way that did not meet the
standards to which I hold myself as
mayor and as a family man
the relationship ended by Mutual consent
earlier this year
during the course of our relationship
some time ago the employee decided to
pursue employment outside City Hall and
secured a job elsewhere
I recognize that permitting this
relationship to develop was a serious
error in judgment on my part
it came at a time when Barb my wife of
40 plus years and I were enjoying many
lengthy periods apart well I carried out
my responsibilities during the pandemic
as a result I've decided that I will
step down as mayor so that I can take
the time to reflect on my mistakes and
to do the work of rebuilding the trust
of my family
I'll be working with the city manager
the city clerk and the deputy mayor
Jennifer McKelvey to ensure an orderly
transition in the coming days
well I deeply regret having to step away
from a job that I love in a city that I
love even more I believe in my heart it
is best to fully commit myself to the
work that is required to repair these
most important relationships
as well I think it is important as I
always have for the office of the mayor
not to be in any way tarnished and not
to see the city government itself but
through a period of prolonged
controversy arising out of this error in
judgment on my part especially in light
of some of the challenges that we face
as a city
I'm deeply sorry and I apologize
unreservedly to the people of Toronto
and to all of those heard by my actions
including my staff my colleagues on city
council and the public service for whom
I have such respect
most of all I apologize to my wife Barb
and to my family who I've let down more
than anyone else
I hope the privacy of all of those
impacted by my actions can be respected
and that includes me I think as you know
that I Am Naturally not I'm naturally a
private person notwithstanding some of
the jobs that I've had over the years
and I hope you'll respect that and the
privacy of everyone else as well
especially my wife and family
I've made the Integrity commissioner
aware of the relationship and ask him to
review it I want to thank the people of
Toronto for trusting me as mayor it has
been the job of a lifetime and while
I've let them down and my family down in
this instance I've nonetheless been
deeply honored by the opportunity to
serve the people of this wonderful City
and I believe that I did some good for
the city that I did make a positive
difference for the city that I truly
love particularly during the pandemic
I'm usually known for taking as many
questions as you want to ask but on this
occasion I think I'll let my statement
speak for itself thank you